hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i'm standing outside a house
this house was bought by one of my
students for
63 pounds now it was creatively financed
and in this video
i'm going to be going around the house
interviewing the student
and showing you exactly how this was
purchased for 63 pounds
the interesting thing is there's a house
just opposite that was in
national media it was all in different
newspapers
because it was being sold for a thousand
pounds and everyone's going oh my gosh
this house has been sold for a thousand
pounds
but here's the thing the house that has
been sold for a thousand pounds
actually had a guide price of a thousand
pounds it actually was sold for 35
000 pounds and on top of that it had
legal charges of 12
000 pounds there was fire damage that
was going to cost tens of thousands of
pounds to fix
so actually even though everyone was
sending out how much of a bargain it was
it wasn't a bargain
this house was a bargain so you're going
to see exactly how it was bought for
just 63 pounds
let's go and find out how
this is josh josh as well how old are
you josh 18. he's 18 years old this
story just gets better and better can i
come in yeah close come on
all right so this looks pretty nice
this looks pretty good tell us what kind
of condition was this in when you first
bought it
it wasn't in good condition it look it
wasn't it wasn't like a
a really gritty refurb but it wasn't a
bad condition it needed work done to it
if you wanted to let it out and get the
top the top tier rent in this area
and this house as well i wanted to go
around this house
because it's yours you've got the keys
for it it's in the bag the chicken is
hatched
but you're 18 you've got a whole bunch
of other stuff in the pipeline right
yeah what's going on
in your life right now so at the moment
i'm looking at my property business in
two ways i've got my own personal
ventures and i've got my sourcing
ventures
sourcing-wise just a few days ago we
secured two deals
we passed them on to a client she's very
happy we're just sorting out everything
we're finalizing that
uh on the other hand with our personal
adventures we're looking for our very
next deal
you've got a massive deal you're looking
at just now we've got a big one but
before we get to that we've got we've
got a couple of smaller ones
yeah a little a step above this a step
above this and
we're looking at those for sourcing
we're looking at those for a couple of
clients we might go for one ourselves
yeah but the big one the the bit the big
one that we're looking at
is it's a huge it's a huge commercial to
residential
version now people are gonna be feeling
sick right now they're gonna be saying
you know you're 17 you must have
you know have millionaire parents that
just throw
your parents did put you through my
education yeah and i have they have
helped you
but no one's giving you money no no
one's giving him money okay
you're you're making moves you've got
support you're getting mentoring you're
getting opportunities so i want
i want you to go through this house most
importantly is everyone's gonna be
thinking
how on earth did you did you did you buy
this for 63 pounds so we're going to
talk about the creative way that you
finance this which would be amazing but
right now
take us through to the next room yeah
sure so this is the living area first of
all
we originally when we're looking at this
my mom's involved in property as well
she's the boss when it comes to
decorating
she wanted the builders originally
wanted all white but my mom just said
grey's a new black so we've got a couple
of tones of grey
we've got a little feature wall here
we've got a few more upstairs we've got
feature walls make it
it has a little bit of life to the
pocket it just does when you've just got
a plain white room it looks like a
doctor's waiting area
you whack a little feature wall and it
just brings a bit of life and
a bit of color to the room so i like it
how much does this fire how much does
fire cost
well funny story actually this uh this
came with the property this belongs to
the previous owner
we've literally just cleaned it up and
it says france making you nice
so you can't have been in terrible
condition when you bought it
like i said it wasn't in terrible like
it's uninhabitable but yeah if you want
to get the top rent in this area
it needs something it needs some work
done to it yeah sure how much you spend
on this in total so this was seven
thousand
four hundred and eighty-five so you
didn't spend a fortune on it
with the house down the road though the
thousand pound house
that needed like fire repair right had
fire damage yeah yeah so it was fire
damage
we were going to look at ourselves and
we did think about it we had the
conversation like
should we just own the entire street
yeah
but um we looked at it and we looked at
the costs and the thing is that capital
it can be using bigger deals and we can
get a bigger return
yeah um but the other day for someone
that's still someone's gold right there
isn't it yeah
and i want to talk as well about the
area and stuff and because i know it's
not the best area
yeah but it depends how you find the
best the figures are not too bad
all right after you so we walk through
here we've got a small little hallway
and then we have the bathroom
now this was originally a wet room um
once again it was this this is probably
one this is the worst area in the house
it was really bad
was it yeah it was it was bad you've
seen the pictures yeah
those are the pictures um but with this
we've completely retired everything
new toilet new sink bath tub wasn't even
there like i said it was a wet room
i like it and honestly the reefer
like is this a new kitchen as well uh no
so the tiles are the same
and the decals here on the side are we
changed the
oven and hob sinks the same so the
kitchen didn't need too much done to it
kitchen was still in pretty good it was
in okay condition it just needed a
little bit of a clean
so you've really done well with what you
had on a small budget
and people might be thinking as well
about the finance of it like hang on you
bought it for
63 pounds and then you spent this like
what
hold up wait for it we're going to get
to exactly how this guy financed it but
how he did it was genius
low maintenance garden like it this
entire part it was completely trashed
we had old for sale signs we had some of
these wooden floorboards they were they
were literally broken pieces
so we got this all tidied up it was all
overgrown and also at the back
as well we've got some work done to the
gutters yeah the gutters here they were
pretty badly damaged so we got that
changed as well completely
the carpets all over here they were
completely trashed
and if you want to look just here behind
on the stairs
this entire sort of wall here it was it
had cracks
going all the way through it so how did
you repair the cracks so we got this
completely replaced so we had a lot of
plastering work done for the property
nice so we've got another feature wall
here as you already said
so another great feature wall and then
we come into the other bedroom
and this is the last room another
feature wall here got a little storage
cupboard
here as well this is two two bedrooms
right yep two bed terrace
i like it so the carpet looks nice it's
a good
gray carpet how did you choose this was
it expensive was it cheap like how did
you come about to choose the carpet
speaking to people in the academy
getting other people's experience and
putting that into your own into your own
business um
one of the things that you can see is
with a with a plain cream carpet
you get a stain there you can it's there
it's going to be really hard to get it
out yeah
because this is two colors right yeah
they're like dark grey intertwined yeah
exactly why did you do that
it if you get if if there's a little
stain it'll conceal it and you just need
the deep carpet clean
to lift it up yeah and you can't see it
you can you can you could spill
something but it wouldn't be so visible
because of the two colors it's deceptive
to the eyes so
like it isn't gonna be plastering was it
just painting oh this was just painting
cool and there's no there was no
wallpaper actually not terrible because
it came in not terrible condition it
needed
a big lift it needed to be tarted up
seven and a half grand
i know people could be saying people can
be saying how did you manage to do
you know a new bathroom carpets how did
you manage to do it you even did
guttering and stuff
for just seven and a half thousand
pounds some people are gonna think that
sounds really cheap
how did you find the builders uh power
of the academy that's it power the
academy speak to other academy members
get a little bit of knowledge from them
you add somebody to them they're going
to add some value to you that's exactly
what i did and
a fellow academy member recommended the
builders because you know what if anyone
doesn't know josh's story
you were on when it was wednesday very
recently and
josh literally shared the whole story of
how he got into property
how his parents instead of putting him
through university
decided to put him through my training
academy which it seems to be paying off
yeah yeah it really does seems to be
paying off i mean you've got this house
which is amazing you've got lots of
other stuff
stuff going on now the question as well
that i want to know
is when you found this property you just
joined the academy
you were 17. yeah
now you're only 18. how did you even
forget forget how did you get a mortgage
and how did you get finance
how did you even buy a house as a
teenager like how is that possible
okay so first of all i didn't buy it it
was bought through a company
okay and were you on the company i okay
so here's this funny story
i was on the director's list we tried to
set up our business bank accounts trying
to get our compliance sorted out both
for
our standard property business our
holdings
and my sourcing company they wouldn't
let it happen so i resigned from both of
them
and i'm still not back on the director's
board yet so what does that mean does
that mean you don't own the house
like i said a company owns it and i have
been blessed that my parents
have um offered to be guarantors um for
the properties technically
see these are some of the nightmares
that you will
face obstacles right yeah exactly see
people say is it
people say this to me all the time is it
possible as a teenager i'm 16 i'm 15.
i'm 18. is it possible the answer is
it's always possible but there's going
to be obstacles and hardships so
you said hang on so you found the house
you set up a company
you're a director of the company and you
tried to buy the house through the
company
which was working but then you ended up
having to resign because you're too
young
and put you have your parents on who are
operating as a guarantor for you yeah
okay so that's there we go that's the
solution what would you have done if
your parents just said no
well look i'm already gonna say here i
am very blessed that my family have been
able to support me
correct but it's about being a problem
solver not a problem creator correct
be creative if you're in a network like
the academy or any or any such property
network try to find
people build relationships build a
network and get one of those individuals
to be a guarantor for you
yes that it's about it's about being
creative and i always say this if you
can find the deals
if you you found this deal yourself yeah
no one gave you a penny
no so if you can find these types of
normally down crazy deagles
and you can package it ready there's
gonna be people that are gonna be happy
to jump on board with your vision
because you've brought the vision and i
think the really important thing i'll
say to any
young people watching this or people
that maybe feel like i've got a problem
i can't never say i can't never say
instead you want to say okay how can i
solve this
solution from the finalists problem and
and the way you solve the solution is by
just bringing value you brought value by
bringing the deal
your parents have hosted it for you same
story as me
my first property i bought i was 17. my
stepdad
held in his name for me yeah that was my
that's my first house
so that makes perfect sense i think what
i want to know josh
is you say this house only ended up
costing you
63 pounds how how did you buy this house
for 63 pounds it's ridiculous
okay so in the end it did end up costing
63 pounds and that was the capital that
was left in the deal and we've done that
as a buyer refurbished refinance rent
okay so you did you use the brr strategy
yeah okay so what is the brr strategy
for anyone that doesn't know
so you're buying a house preferably in a
really bad condition where you can add
value
you're then refurbishing the property
and then you're refinancing it so you're
remortgaging the property and you're
pulling up the equity
ah so okay so basically you're you're
putting money in
and you were able to borrow that money
again
based on how good the deal was yeah so
it all comes down to
if you're starting out i haven't got
money i haven't got anyone that will
help me i haven't got
no one will help you probably because
you haven't got good deals
no one will finance you because you
haven't got good deals so
what josh did as a 17 year old after
doing some training was he was like
and i said this to you when you start
the academy i remember i was like
i don't even worry about anything else
don't worry about the xyz until you've
started walking the abc what you've got
to think about is finding good deals
find the good deals people then start
getting around you so josh finds
a really good deal and then suddenly
voila like that so many people
banks um joint venture partners academy
members
parents whoever and people might say and
i know in the last video on the windows
wednesday people are i wish my posts
helped me
go find a good deal then and then maybe
suddenly people will start because
that's what josh did your parents aren't
really rich your parents aren't they
didn't give you a pen but what they did
do
was they saw the deal which you found
and they're like hmm
and they agreed that they would finance
the deal on the basis that they got all
of the money back upon refund is that
correct exactly okay so talk to me about
how that worked
so like you just explained there i found
the deal i presented the figures to them
i showed them complete in-depth detail
um due diligence that i gathered on this
deal they came out they saw it
and what i did what i said to them was
that you're going to be putting your
money in
and you are going to pull it out you're
already going to be leaving 63 pounds on
the deal
now for the rent it's going to make that
back in the first month anyway
yeah and for them all that they're the
way you've got to look at is you're
recycling your cash
and for them they've done that and now
they've got a property and they're
wanting to help you out as well right
yeah exactly because you're their son
but the interesting thing is lots of our
academy members who are also young
they've done they've managed to poor
people in other academy members other
so figures wise so what was the initial
i know you left 63 pounding what was the
initial
purchase price of this house because it
didn't get attention from the media
because it wasn't a thousand pounds but
you were creative so how much did you
actually initially
purchase this house for so originally
the asking price was 45
and they were they were very highly
motivated seller we managed to negotiate
that down to 395.
we're not paying stamp duty because we
purchased a property five pounds below
forty thousand
nice and where did you learn that had me
academy that's the thing getting
education money follows
okay so you bought it for 39.99
that's how much cash you put in which
your parents
actually funded initially with a view to
getting it back real soon yeah exactly
you then spent you've already said you
didn't spend
about seven and a half thousand pound on
the refurb 7485 to be precise
all right cool so you've put you've put
40 grand in approximately and then seven
and a half grand approximately so now
about about
47 and a half grand in yeah you don't
pay any tax or stamps you say because of
the value of the house
you've just had this house re-valued
what was it revalued at so before we get
to revaluing we of course have the legal
costs as well which are 984
and 350 for a survey so the total
investment was
48 813 we then of course the the
the valuation was 65 000 by that on a 75
loan to value mortgage we can then get
that at 48 750
minus 48 813 by 48 750
that's leaving 63 pounds 63 pounds yeah
so and that's literally taken into
account survey legal
legal costs exactly everything 63 pounds
so that is how you creatively
finance a deal absolutely awesome now
what some people might say though josh
is
yeah okay it's 63 pounds but it's a
little rubbish house and a little
rubbish area
so what's what are the ongoing cash flow
gonna be so you put 63 pounds in
how much of the mortgage payments have
you got tenants interested what are the
tenants going to be paying
what's happening on that front okay so
first of all with the mortgage payments
that's 97 pounds a month so it's not
it's not breaking the bank it's not it's
not tons
that's interest only right that's
interest only correct crazy cheap
crazy cheap and the rent so the rent the
achievable rent for the standards
property we can get 475 pounds
yeah but the thing is the area it's not
the greatest in the world it's not it's
rough
it's rough it is rough but it's not it's
not super bad but
it's there so you have to be picky with
your tenants that's one thing that i'd
say to
anyone right if you're investing in a
bit of a in a bit of a rough area
you've got to be picky with your tenants
because most likely you're going to get
a bad tenant so you want to make sure
that your property which is your product
it stays in a good condition because
your tenant is going to move out
eventually
and if they've left the place trash
that's more capital that's
having to be invested into this deal
yeah and then it's no longer an asset it
just becomes
a liability correct you've learned well
my friend
i've actually i've actually honestly
i've had houses that i've bought with no
money down
but then they've become a liability
because they've been rough and have a
bad tenants in there so
i'm really glad that you've learned from
my mistakes on some of my early early
houses
so if you're going to be renting this
out for 475 mortgage payments 97 pound a
month
you might have obviously got a little
bit of insurance and a couple things
like management
but you're going to be left with a
monthly cash flow of how much you're
expecting each month
uh we're expecting around about two
around about 200 pounds a month
so the total investment total house is
63 pounds they're making 200 pounds a
month
that's 2 400 a year the return on
investment on that
is i don't know what it is but it's
going to be absolutely crazy scott high
should probably work that out actually
yeah we should work that out so if he's
making 2
400 a year profit after all costs that's
his total annual profit
divided by the total amount he invested
which was 63 pounds
means that his end return on investment
times 100
is 3809 percent
return on investment which is absolutely
incredible how do you feel
you must be well proud of this house for
a fast deal i'm really happy and
it's put it's put into perspective that
if if you could do this as your first
deal think of what your tenth deal is
going to be like i think about where
20th is going to be like what's my
advice being to you now moving forward
like what's the plan moving forward
after this house
so just don't don't jump in the deep end
just yet try to scale it up
one step at a time yeah so the next one
that we're looking at we're not looking
at a two bed terrace now we're looking
at something a little bit bigger a semi
uh like a three bed semi which is what
we are that's our initial goal now yes
because after that because you're always
going to make mistakes on your first
deal and i said this to josh i said
start something really small
test that it works see the return on
investment coming in
see the money come back build
credibility get people's trust build
your reputation and then what's going to
happen is
your confidence will go up your first
deal is always your hardest you're going
to make mistakes you don't want to make
mistakes on a big massive deal
you want to make mistakes on a little
deal and then get bigger and bigger and
bigger
and honestly i mean imagine imagine what
he's going to be doing when he's 25
years old i'm excited bro
i think the biggest thing for me is the
fact that josh is just taking massive
action
like 18 years old most 18 years i
wouldn't even have the confidence
wouldn't have the i mean honestly i'm
impressed man
josh talk to me what's the three
most important factors to being
successful in business even if you're
starting with no money
with an age where you're super young
what should people do
number one i'd definitely say be
conservativity figures i've been i've
been very conservative with these
figures
always work on worst case scenario
because if anything if it's better than
the worst case
then it's just more it's more money yeah
like we worked on the basis that you
were gonna be making two thousand four
hundred
but that you'd factor in not just ten
percent management ten percent voids
but you'd also factor in things like
damages
and extra costs because of the area
because the area is a little bit
talk about this thing so what you just
said about um
cost voids damages it leads to this for
example now we've just
we've repaired this very quickly but
this this entire drain drain
yeah someone literally just can't just
kick this
who does that who would just kick a dre
but this is the kind of thing that
sometimes you need to factor in so
you've got to be conservative on your
fingers
because if you don't ever allow for
anything to go wrong yeah and then
something goes wrong and then you're oh
man i'm down this month so you've been
really conservative all right next
okay the next thing i'll definitely say
is with that persistence you're gonna
have there's gonna be a lot of
a lot of obstacles a lot of hurdles that
come in your way a little damage like
that for someone they might just decide
to pull the plugger on that yeah
on their business so it's about when you
have all these
all these little things that happen that
are going to try to put you down
you keep in your mind the goal and
what's what's what's there for you
the more you push what's going to happen
the good things that are going to come
along when you push through the hard
time
so definitely persistence is a really
really big thing and that's something
that i took along in sourcing
i struggled to sell i struggled to sell
deals when i got started yeah because i
didn't know what i was doing but when
you when you keep your mind focused on
it
you'll get there in time i say what the
on sourcing and stuff
i would buy a deal from you like i would
buy a deal from you because just because
you're 18 years old
you know your stuff man like you you
know your figures you know your stuff
you're good at finding deals just some
of the deals you've been showing me some
of the plans for some of the properties
that you're looking at later today i'm
looking at them i'm like
how is this 18 year old but sometimes
you need to forget like
people think in terms of age like oh
you're 18 and who's the
most most 40 year olds don't know
anything about investment
so it's nothing to do with age it has
everything to do with experience as
everything's new whether you've been
trained or not
and you've been trained you're
experienced you know your stuff i
definitely would buy a deal from you
number three number three number three
so action taking all day long all day
long action taking is the big one
if you have something that you need to
do and it's for your business
it doesn't matter if you're tired if
you're yawning you could be up at
midnight one two three
four it doesn't matter what hour of the
night you're up you need to just take
the action and just not stop until you
get the job done
best best thing that i've done and it
and it's paid off it's paid off in this
deal
yeah if there's if there's a webinar
going on if there's a call attend the
call
yes prioritize that put that write it on
your mirror on your board it doesn't
matter make sure that you do it
and put what you put in you get out yeah
i say it all the time what you put in
you get out same with school if you go
to university
if you're going to party and stuff and
you're going to have the night life in
uni you're not going to get as good as a
degree
if you actually work then you're going
to get it same thing with business dude
ridiculously pleased to see your success
very very smart guy
very very smart guy i hope you've
learned a lot from watching this drop a
comment below what was the top thing
that you learned from watching this
video
drop a comment below and also let me
know what kind of video do you want to
see next what kind of projects you want
to go to do you want to see
more of josh do you want to see
something a little bit different comment
below what you want to see
if you want to learn more about the buy
refurbished refinance strategy
you can check out this video right here
if you want to see josh's winners on a
wednesday story you can check that out
right here
and of course don't forget to subscribe
and you can do that right here thanks so
much for watching
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you